[Musique]
il reste parfois sur les tablettes leur
contenu n'était respecte toujours le
grand public et pourtant ils ont
tellement d'histoires racontées les
livres de la bibliothèque du parlement
c'est un peu comme ce qu'on appelle les
députés d'arrière-ban on ne pense pas
toujours à les consulter
[Musique]
les journalistes carriole m'initier prix
et d'autres qui existe à l'heure pas de
réponse emilie posture la députée de
charlevoix côte de beaupré et claire
isabelle qui représente en taille donne
toutes les deux pour la caq nous
rencontrent ici un clin d'oeil alors
longues études doctorales c'est dur de
rester sur les bancs arrière quand je
vois tout ce qui se passe en termes de
malaise démocratique parce que moi c'est
ma spécialité en communication publique
ma thèse de doctorat portait l'action
les deux sont maintenant libres de paris
sans retenue ni ligne de parti parce
qu'elle quitte la politique après un
seul mandat elle regrette d'ailleurs de
le faire sans avoir achevé la réforme
parlementaire tant attendu abandonnés
par leur gouvernement
faute de temps et parce que ce n'était
pas la priorité moi je pense qu'on a eu
du progrès à faire sur les comptes sont
qu on offre aux parlementaires
cette réforme prévoyait entre autres de
finir les travaux parlementaires à 18h
la possibilité aussi pour les députés
proches aidants de s'absenter un congé
parental d'un an fait aussi partie des
propositions
avoir une garderie également au
parlement pour les jeunes mamans j'en ai
vu plein pour qui ça aurait été
tellement utile ça changerait leur mythe
mais il n'ya pas que les horaires sont
veut attirer des gens de qualité dans
cette fonction là oui je pense qu'ils
devraient avoir discussion également sur
le salaire des élus dans la prochaine
législature poser en urgence si vous
voulez vous impliquer mais c'est pas
pour la salade c'est vraiment parce
qu'il ya quelque chose en politique que
vous voulez jour monde fille karine
boivin wa
liberty ont beau multiplier les efforts
pour recruter les femmes ils ne
parviendront pas à les garder longtemps
avec un salaire de base de 95 mille
dollars et des conditions difficiles
parmi la trentaine de députés qui
partent cette année les deux tiers sont
des femmes même si elles prennent de
plus en plus leur place elles doivent
encore prouver qu elle la mérite
et se battre contre des perceptions des
choses aussi banales que leur abymes
juste avant le débat mais j'ai un homme
qui me dit bonjour madame
vous porter la même robe que lorsque je
vous ai vu la dernière fois
c'est le premier commentaire qu'on vous
fait premier commentaire qu'on va faire
effectivement je me disais ce qu ils
voulaient me déstabiliser avant de
commencer mon des bords elle a grandi
sur une ferme mais dès le début des
agriculteurs de son comté ont douté
d'elle parce que c'est une
intellectuelle mais qu'est ce qu'on va
faire deux profs d'université est une
femme en politique ça veut dire se faire
dire de retourner à ses chaudrons parce
qu'il reste encore je m'excuse de
l'expression des vieux macho il ya
récents car j'ai déjà reçu même en privé
des messages sur messenger le de photos
aux erreurs j'ai déjà reçu ce oui d
avance vraiment déplacé
d'autres lignes aurait carrément malgré
ses 11 ans d'implication à la cac je
suis avec des maires qui sont tous des
hommes qui ont un autre marie laure
servent tous la main et puis moi c'est
comme si je n'existais pas ça m'est
arrivé
j'ai passé quatre ans à m'expliquer
expliquer mon parcours parce que souvent
les gens sont beaucoup d hommes
m'abordaient de façon très paternaliste
tu devrais faire telle chose comme si j
avais pas passer emilie déplore aussi
les commentaires à l'annoncé de son
départ on se fait vers 14 quai de la
politique que c'est parce qu'on est
tombé en amour ce qui est plutôt
difficile sur l'orgueil mais on se fait
dire ce genre de chose ou est ce qu'un
homme se ferait de dire un commentaire
comme ça on dirait que lui par pour une
meilleure un meilleur emploi par exemple
oui ou pour des raisons familiales mais
certainement pas parce qu'il a trouvé
l'amour vous comprenez réaction aussi
étonnantes quand les isabelle a annoncé
sa décision au maire de son comté auprès
qui elle s'est acharnée à faire ses
preuves il y en a qui m'ont boudé lors
jusque jusqu'à la semaine dernière parce
qu'on a eu une activité et j'étais
obligée de dylan et vont bouder
longtemps encore parce qu'on a des
dossiers à régler et les députés en
règle des dossiers quoi qu'en disent
leur ancien collègue les députés plantes
vertes comme on ne va pas travailler
prend depuis deux ans le
découragés par les perceptions négatives
claire a décidé d'animer des ateliers
pour revaloriser le rôle du député moi
je me serais posé à maintes reprises est
ce que vous êtes ministre non à la
déception la voir la déception chez les
le travail pour être qu'il est méconnu
mais les substantielles et c'est du 24 7
la charge comporte ses 24 sept
malgré tous les deux n'ont jamais
regretté d'avoir fait le saut souvent on
est ce un peu de nous mettre dans un bol
en politique la russie comme ça pour
tous les partis l'eau mais c'est
important d'être authentique d'être soi
et de foncer
l'assemblée nationale se réfère à ses
livres pour souligner les grands moments
de son histoire mais peut-être
devra-t-il aussi se référer davantage à
ce qu'on appelle les simples députés qui
elle veut réaliser d'autres pas en avant
il se dit véronique prince radio canada
québec